l'ump en tant que tel dans les
consultations dans les cmp il a cinq
fois plus de couple ou de femmes qui
viennent pour les problèmes avec leurs
enfants
cette fois plus et du côté des
célibataires temps à cinq fois plus que
les célibataires qui viennent
classiquement très souvent ce sont des
difficultés que traverse et les parents
et les enfants
c'est à dire que des parents qui sont
envahis par l'imaginaire du donneur par
exemple peu cela peut entraîner chez le
père de l'enfant le fait pas se sentir
tout à fait père et puis même chose pour
les donneuses d'ovocytes c'est-à-dire
oms on pensait que la que l'accouchement
était extrêmement matérialisant un et
ben on se rend compte que même chez ces
femmes qui accouchent de l'enfant qui a
été conçu avec un don d'ovocytes et avec
le sperme du mari
on se rend compte que chez ces femmes là
si elles sont envahis par l'imaginaire
biologiques elles auront du mal à se
sentir mer il ya une très jolie histoire
c'est l'histoire justement de cette mère
qui va annoncer à sa fille qu'elle est
issue justement d'un don de sperme au
moment où l'enfant pose des questions
sur la conception comment fait-on les
enfants ce qui est extrêmement classique
et 7 mai lui dis bah voilà donc il ya la
graine de maman galagan de papa et puis
ça fait un bébé était à bon et
d'ailleurs la graine de papa elle venait
pas de papa est tout de suite la
réaction de l'enfance et avant donc papa
n'est pas papa l'enfant avait 6 ans et
alors la mère fait une réponse très
psychanalytique et visionner sur la zone
des attentats
il a donné la graine à papa oui donc
c'est la douane de papa oui donc c'est
papa c'est à dire que le l'enfant a tout
de suite mis en place une fiction qui
marche c'est à dire que il fait comme si
cette graine c'était celle de son père
et c'est la même chose dans l'adoption
où les enfants font comme si ce père
était le père et donc du coup pour
l'enfance est le vrai père est la vraie
mère l'un des plus importants problèmes
de cette loi c'est véritablement de
sortir la filiation de désincarné la
filiation par rapport à cette scène
originaire procréative le fait de
considérer que toute femme seules deux
femmes ensemble
renvoi l'enfant a quelque chose d'une
conception
impossible donc impensable donc
désincarné
oui mais déjà on le voyait dans les
adoptions par les femmes seules à quel
point c'était plus difficile et plus
compliqué la mp en tant que tel dans les
consultations dans les cmp il a cinq
fois plus de couple ou de femmes qui
viennent pour les problèmes avec leurs
enfants
cinq fois plus et du côté des
célibataires temps à cinq fois plus que
les célibataires qui viennent
classiquement ces femmes là viennent
nous voir en consultation donc elles
sont pas du tout dans le discours
militant c'est facile c'est ban voilà
c'est banal il suffit d'un peu d'amour
pour y arriver non elles sont pas dans
ce discours là elles sont dans le
discours j'ai des difficultés et des
mois à savoir comment faire comment
faire pour nommer cette filiation
comment faire pour assumer le fait qu'
il y ait un contournement justement de
l'homme pour avoir l'enfant
c'est pour cela qu'une chose est le fait
de se retrouver femmes seules deux par
les aléas de la vie qui sont complexes
avec un homme absent un homme qui a
disparu
un homme pas là etc mais ce n'est pas la
même chose d'assumé cette scène d'une
procréatique par rapport à l'enfant y
compris dans la disparition que
d'institutionnaliser la disparition d'un
père même pas la disparition de
l'absence de perth
parce que c'est compliqué d'assumer ce
cheminement de et de répondre aux
questions de l'enfant pourquoi tu as
voulu que je n'ai pas de père tous les
cliniciens et tous les pédopsychiatres
et pédopsychologue qui travaillait sur
cette question ben on est assez on est
assez convergent sur ceux sur ces points
là
c'est une expérience que l'on a
science c'est à dire que plus une
filiation hypertrophie le biologique
plus cela atteint le psychique et c'est
pour ça que voilà une filiation qui
repose sur trois piliers le juridique le
psychique et le biologique
si le juridique ne tient pas compte de
cela c'est à dire ne rééquilibre pas le
psychique et bien cela fragilise
énormément la filiation et c'est
exactement ce qui se passe avec ce
projet de loi dans l'adoption dans la
majeure partie des cas ça se passe bien
parce que voilà c'est à dire il y avait
sept
cette première filiation qui était
justement une impasse fils hâtives et
une création filia tive par l'adoption
même chose pour le don c'est à dire
justement c'est un don et c'est pas un
prêt c'est à dire c'est pas ben voilà on
va vous le donner mais ensuite on va on
va vous dire le nom du géniteur c'est à
dire ça mais une sorte d'épée de
damoclès pendant les dix huit ans de
l'enfant où l'enfant pourra penser quand
sa chance est informatif tous les
problèmes de sa vie seront résolus ce
qui est un leurre total
oui c'est à dire le plus grand
problème bien sûr c'est la politisation
du désir d'enfant le président du ccn eu
à prononcer justement cette phrase je
n'ai strictement rien contre le droit à
l'enfant au contraire donc c'est pas une
phrase qui vient de nulle part
tandis que c'est quelque chose qui est
assumée si je puis dire parce qu'ils ont
donnée justement le feu vert à toutes
ces techniques malgré justement toutes
les limites et tout les points deux buts
et qu'il y a eu dans les états généraux
de la bioéthique points deux buts et qui
ont tous été balayés c'est à dire on
sait que c'est plus compliqué on sait
que c'est plus difficile
on sait que c'est plus risqué pour
l'enfant mais peu importe nous sommes
favorables à ce droit à l'enfant